Guten Tag. Ja, guten Tag. Ich bin Krimaz und hier erstes. Ich werde mit das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid für etwas Unklares. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Anna Kehl.
Anna Kehl. Wie ist Vornamen und Nachnamen?
Vornamen ist Anna, A-N-A. Und der Familienname ist Kehl, K-E-H-L.
Danke. Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 69 Jahre und bin geboren am 19.56.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 168 und wiege zur Zeit so 79 kg, knapp unter 80.
Welche Beschweiten haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe seit ein paar Tagen Schmerzen in den Bauch.
Das hat angefangen vor fast zwei Wochen.
Es geht auch schon wieder weg.
Insbesondere nach dem Essen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Aber seit zwei Tagen ist es richtig schlimm geworden.
Was mich schon ein bisschen erschreckt hat,
ich habe mich die letzten Tage zweimal übergeben.
Das war ganz klar, da war blutiges Zeug mit drin.
Das sah ganz eklig aus.
Jetzt muss ich aber doch mal ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Wie sieht Ihr Erbruch aus?
Ja, Essen ist Reste und dann waren da ganz eindeutig Blutspuren drin.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen,
zum Beispiel beschreiben, kramfartig?
Ja, es drückt ganz einfach.
Es ist so dumfer Druck.
Es bohrt sich in den oberen Bauch rein.
Sie schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nein, sie sind nur hier oben im Bauch.
Ich würde sagen, oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Haben Sie gestern neues Essen oder vertreiches Essen?
Ja, ich habe schon gemerkt, dass überhaupt Essen unangenehm ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es schon immer dann, wenn man etwas Fettiges ist,
dass es dann noch schlechter ist.
Aber ich habe die ganzen Tage gar nicht so doll Fettiges Essen gegessen,
weil mir schon so schlecht war.
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe auch überhaupt gar keinen Appetit.
Es gibt bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich esse, dann ist es besonders schlimm.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen,
aber ich fühle mich total schwitzig.
Nacht schwitze ich auch sehr.
Das ist mir jetzt aufgefallen,
dass ich richtig nass geschwitzt bin.
Leiden Sie an beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang Probleme?
Eigentlich habe ich da keine Probleme.
Aber das, was mir aufgefallen ist beim Stuhlgang,
sah letztens ganz dunkel aus, viel dunkler als sonst.
Hat Ihr Haut oder Augenläder Farbe verwendet?
Zum Beispiel gelbliche Farbe?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen,
aber ich habe auch nicht so gutes Licht im Badeszimmer am Spiegel.
Aber habe ich nicht gesehen?
Nein, wüsste ich nicht.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwärte?
Ja, wie gesagt, mir ist es schlecht.
Ich fühle mich auch total schlapp.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich komme überhaupt nicht in die Gänge.
Und die Schmerzen sind langsam schon,
dass sie mich einschränken.
Haben Sie schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir eigentlich nicht.
Aber schlapp fühle ich mich.
Leiden Sie unter Sortbrennen oder Sauros Aufstoß?
Nein, ich habe damit keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden?
Nein, wie Haltschmerzen.
Ich habe das nicht.
Natürlich ist das unangenehm,
als ich mich da übergeben musste.
Weil es kratzt, der dann immer hinterher im Heiz.
Weil es so sauer ist.
Aber so richtig Haltschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Schutelfrost?
Nein, ich habe geschwitzt.
Ich habe geschwitzt in der Nacht.
Haben Sie ihn ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen.
Aber das liegt daran.
Ich bekomme Cortison, weil ich so Arthritis habe.
Rollmatoide Arthritis.
Damit ich das überhaupt aushalten kann,
bekomme ich Bretenesolon.
Da habe ich in letzter Zeit ein paar Kilo zugenommen.
Wissen Sie, wie viele Kilo?
Das sind schon 2-3 Kilo obendrauf.
Ich würde sagen 2 Monate.
Ich fühle mich damit auch nicht besonders gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich habe nicht so viele Schmerzen geschlafen.
Ich verstehe sehr gut.
Manchmal ist diese Situation unangenehm.
Schlafen Sie die krönliche Erkrankung bis auf Rollmatoide Arthritis?
Ja, ich habe noch so ein bisschen so Husten, so Brontitis.
Ich muss oft mal so ein bisschen bis Schleimhoch husten.
Aber was ich noch habe,
dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe.
Seit wann haben Sie Rollmatoide Arthritis, Brontitis und Arterialypertone?
Ja, die Brontitis, das ist immer mal wieder zur Zeit.
Jetzt, wo es so kalt geworden ist, hat es wieder angefangen.
Aber das habe ich eigentlich auch schon Jahre lang.
Das ist immer wieder so aufslammt im Winter,
dass ich husten muss und so.
Aber hier mit dem Blutdruck,
das hat man so vor 10 Jahren ungefähr bestellt.
Rollmatoide Arthritis?
Ja, das fing so langsam an,
aber die Diagnose ist auch so ziemlich genau vor 10 Jahren gestellt worden.
Gib es noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, bisher war ich immer ganz zufrieden.
Ich bin so klar gekommen, wie es ist.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit stationär behandelt?
Nein, ich war schon lange nicht mehr im Krankenhaus zum Glück.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Aber schon ganz lange her.
Als ich ein junges Mädchen war,
da hatte ich mal im rechten Knie das Kreuzband gerissen
und das musste operiert werden.
Aber das ist nur schon sehr, sehr lange her.
Da habe ich eigentlich jetzt auch nichts mehr von gemerkt.
Aber die Arthritis, das merke ich natürlich nicht,
dass das in allen Gelenken wehtut.
Gib es noch eine Operation?
Nee, sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Doch, warten Sie, ich habe natürlich irgendwann mal den Blinter rausbekommen.
Wie lange ist denn das her?
Das ist bestimmt schon, war ich vielleicht zu 25 oder so?
55.
Wann waren Sie in der Knie-Operation?
Das war, als ich 18 war.
Sind Sie vorstandig gehn?
Ja, so viel ich weiß.
Ja, also ich bin da nicht so gründlich.
Covid habe ich jetzt lange Zeit keine Impfung bekommen.
Die letzte liegt, glaube ich, schon 2 Jahre zurück.
Aber ich habe damals 3 Impfungen, glaube ich, bekommen.
Ich verstände.
War Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war, bin gar nicht viel unterwegs gewesen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein, bis auf der pürieten Sonne?
Ja, ich habe noch ein Mittel gegen Blutstuhlfruk.
Das ist, Kapto-Opril heißt das.
Dann nehme ich morgens und abends jeweils eine.
Wie viel Dosierung?
Oh, das ist, mein 25 steht da drauf.
35 Milligramm.
Ich war da 25, 35, also irgendwie sowas.
Und nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und dann, wenn ich richtig schlimme Schmerzen habe,
dann nehme ich auch mal die Klophenack.
Viel viel Dosierung?
Ja, das sind, meine ich, das gibt es da 50 Milligramm,
sind das, glaube ich.
Präten soll, wie häufig nehmen Sie?
Viel viel Dosierung?
Das nehme ich einmal morgens und das sind 15 Milligramm.
15?
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergen oder eine Fertiglichkeit?
Ich kann nicht alles vertraben.
Also, ich bin nicht allergisch,
kriege ich keinen Ausschlag oder irgendwie so Kontakt?
Nee, wüsste ich das nicht, ich habe keine Allergen.
Super.
Schaufen Sie?
Allerdings ja, ja, ja.
Ich rauche schon so, Päckchen am Tag geht schon durch.
Schon seit vielen Jahren, also eigentlich, seit ich erwachsen bin.
Ich verstehe.
Aber wenn Sie möchten,
kann ich im Krankenhaus entwuchsungsprogramm anbieten.
Auch in meinem Alter muss ich das auch nicht mehr aufführen,
das ist auch egal.
Wissen Sie, jetzt die Zigaretten schmecken mir halt so gut, ne?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Zum Abendbrot trinke ich eigentlich regelmäßig ein Glas Bier
und dann trinken wir abends auch manchmal noch ein Glas Wein oder zwei Jahre.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, schon bestimmt, also viele Jahre.
Also, als die Kinder auf die Welt gekommen sind, nicht,
danach, als ich da keine Rücksicht mehr nehmen musste,
dann trinke ich schon ziemlich lange.
Okay.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht Person nicht.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, nein, das nehme ich nicht.
Alkohol, ja, aber keine Drogen, nein, nein.
Ich verstehe, gibt es in jeder Familie bestimmte Erkrankungen?
Ja, also mein Vater hat den Herzinfarkt, das weiß ich ja.
Und meine Mutter, die war aber eigentlich bis ins hohe Alter ziemlich fit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, woran die tatsächlich gestorben ist.
Aber die hatte nicht irgendwie eine schwerwiegende Erkrankung,
die war einfach alt.
Die Mutter ist wegen alter Schwäche gestorben?
Ja, denke ich mal, da war nicht bekannt, dass sie irgendwas Schlimmes hat.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie, ich habe zwei Brüder und noch eine Schwester.
Sind Ihre Geschwister gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja, ja.
Super.
Ich weiß, wir sprechen nicht täglich, aber grundsätzlich sind Sie eigentlich gesund, ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe zwei, die sind aber schon groß natürlich, keine Kinder mehr.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund, ja, klar.
Sie sind ja noch jung.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Hausfrau, ich habe nie richtig, ich habe mal zwischendurch ein bisschen sauber gemacht
und mal so bisschen Geld dazu verdient, aber nie richtig festgearbeitet.
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Treiben Sie ein regelmäßig Sport?
Na ehrlich gesagt nicht, nein.
Früher bin ich noch Fahrrad gefahren oder sind wir im Sommer mal schwimmen gegangen,
aber da bin ich jetzt schon zu faul dazu.
Das war nun eine meiner Fragen, ob Sie etwas für Ihre Frau haben?
Eigentlich habe ich Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt, ich möchte jetzt natürlich wissen,
woher die Schmerzen kommen und ja, ob das gefährlich ist
und dass man dagegen tun kann und ob ich in Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Will ich natürlich alles wissen, ja.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
So als werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen dann auch Blut abnehmen.
Zunächst werde ich weitere Schritte informieren Sie, was es losgeht und Ihre Behandlung informieren.
Okay, okay.
Und geht es jetzt gleich los mit den Untersuchungen?
Warten Sie Fragen?
Nein, ich habe, ob es jetzt gleich losgeht mit den Untersuchungen.
Bitte warten Sie in Untersuchung, Sie machen.
Okay, ja, ja.
Gut.
Ja, bis dann.
Hat jemand noch zusätzlichen Fragen?
Könnten Sie letzte Satz wiederholen?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Verstanden.
Ja, ja.
Was habe ich denn letztes gesagt?
Ich habe glaube ich nur gesagt, dass ich nicht, dass ich, dass ich Sorge habe und,
dass ich, ach so, genau, ich wollte wissen, ob es jetzt mit den Untersuchungen losgeht.
Ich habe gesagt, geht es jetzt los mit den Untersuchungen?
Okay, danke.
Das war es, glaube ich, ja.
So etwas Schwieriges, das habe ich gerade eben geredet, ja.
Okay.
Schrauen Sie Schmerzen, ihr galt nur ihn auf?
Nein, ich strahle nicht aus.
Sie sind nur im Oberbau, ganz, ganz nur, also oberhalb vom Bauchennabel.
Hat sie aber auch gefragt, tatsächlich, ja.
Ich konnte nicht genau folgen, ob Schmerzinsenste gefragt wurde.
Glaube ist nicht gefragt worden.
Ja, also Schmerzen gibt sie jetzt mit 7 von 10.
Und ja, nachdem sie sich übergeben hat, fühlt sie sich ein bisschen besser an.
Also dann sind die Schmerzen klein wenig weniger.
Aber kommen dann nachher wieder.
Nehmen Sie einen Magenschutz ein?
Ah, auch eine gute Frage.
Magenschutz, nee, weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist.
Was soll der Magenschutz sein?
Also sie nehmen keine Medikamente zum Magenschutz.
Hatte Sie früher ähnliche Symptome oder Beschwerde?
Ja, eine gute Frage.
Nee, also solche Schmerzen kenne ich gar nicht.
Frau Doktorelle, wenn Sie so weit sind, sagen Sie Bescheid, ne?
Guten Tag Frau Obersteinin.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute neue Patientinnen vorstellen.
Eine neue Patientin, Frau?
Eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Frau Karl ist...
Kirl heißt die Nürburgring.
Kirl, Kirl.
Kirl ist 69-jährige Patientin.
Die sich durch wegen zwei Wochen epigastrische Abdominalgie
und zweimal ehemma-temesis,
Bayerens Forstelte,
Dschmerz Intensität ist sieben von Sein auf dem Arschesekala.
Die Schmerzen sind...
Schmerzen sind Plural.
Die Schmerzen sind nach vertreich-... vertreichisches Malzeiten...
Nach vertreicher Malzeiten, ja?
Vertreihem Malzeit, schlimmer geworden.
Und ohne Strahlen.
Ist Strahlen nicht aus?
Die Strahlen nicht aus.
Die Fragen nach...
Erfieber,
Vertigo, Dispepsi,
Sotbremnen wurden verneint.
Die Patienten klacken über,
nächtliche Hyperhydrosi
und Dunkelirin,
Zovey, Fatigue.
Die epigastrische Schmerzen sind
bestehende Dunferty-...
die Schmerzen.
Die vegetative Anamnesen
ist bis auf
Schmerzbedingte Insomni-
und Inapotens.
So wie in der Halb,
ein Monat,
2 oder 3 kg
Su genomen.
Gewichtsunahmen.
Anforarkrankungen leidet...
Moment, Moment.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf
diese Punkte
unauffällig.
Bis auf...
Wir haben gesagt,
die vegetative Anamnese...
Unauffällig.
Da fehlt dir das Wort.
Aber, da muss ich gleich intervenieren.
Wenn 4 Punkte in der vegetativen Anamnese sind,
dann ist die nicht unauffällig.
Das ist die auffällig.
Aber bis auf...
Ja, aber dann muss man...
Eine andere Beschwaltung?
In der vegetativen Anamnese beschreibt die Patientin
nachtsfalls Inapotens-
Gewichtsunahme,
die sie auf die Koalitionsgabe allerdings zurückführt.
Und, ja, dann ist es aber nicht mehr unauffällig.
Das kann man nicht sagen.
Ja?
Das ist ja auffällig.
Genug Punkte, der geht ja schlecht.
Gut, jetzt können Sie weitermachen.
Entschuldigung.
Danke.
Anforarkrankungen leidet an die Patientin
seit 10 Jahren
Romatoides Arthritis.
Von Rheumaturina Arthritis.
Seit langer Jahren
seit 10 Jahren Arterial-Hypertonie.
Anfor-Operationen
in Assent Lebensjahr
rechten Knie-Operationen wegen Kreuzband-Ries.
Ah, ja, okay.
So wie 25. Lebensjahr.
Und 25. Lebensjahr?
Lebensjahr apandectomie.
Reisanamnese ist unauffällig.
Sie ist vorstandig geimpft.
Sie nimmt Regenmezi,
Prätnisolone,
50 Milligramm Morganz,
Kaptobril, 530 Milligramm Morganz
und Abends,
Dick Lofanak, 510 Milligramm
Bay Bedarf.
Sie hat keine bekannte Allergie
und die Frage ist,
seit 22. Lebensjahr
eine Einpackung
täglich.
Sude, trink sie
Einglasbia täglich
und manchmal ein oder zwei Glas Wein.
Oh ja.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Mutter hat wegen Alteswege gestorben.
Ist ein Alteswege gestorben?
Ist wegen Alteswege gestorben.
Der Vater ist wegen Myokartinfarktus gestorben.
Sie hat zwei Brüder
und ein gesundes Schwester.
Außerdem ist sie verheiratet
und hat zwei gesunde Erwachsene Kinder.
Frau Kehl ist Hausfrau.
Sude treibt sie nicht regelmäßig Sport.
Sie hat die Annamnestischen Angaben am 1.
auf Urkus-Wendzschücheli
mit Obergastherointestinal-Bulutung.
Oder was könnte es noch sein?
Was wäre differentialdiagnostisch noch möglich?
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen
mit Magna Karzinom,
Zofi,
Özefagus Karzinom,
oder weniger dramatisch
Özefagus, Barrett,
das könnte es auch noch sein.
Was machen die Diagnostisch jetzt mit der Patientin?
Ich werde die Abdomenpapieren,
Oskeltieren, Inspektieren,
Insprezieren,
die Inspektion, aber das Verb heißt Inspektieren.
Sonex werde ich Abdomenal-Zonografie durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte Abdomenal-Zonografie,
Freiflüssigkeit,
oder Schleimhaut, Veränderungen.
Und was erwarten Sie bei der Pallpation
und Auskultation?
In diesem Fall ist es wichtig,
lasst los,
loslasst.
Loslasst.
Worauf achten Sie noch bei dem allerersten Aspekt
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Die Hautfarbe,
die Zyanose,
und das Ichterus.
Ja, ichterus.
Was machen Sie dann nach dem Ultraschall?
Ich werde die Entuskopie-Entusung aufnehmen.
Ja.
Im Labor werde ich Blutbild,
Gerinnungparameter, Entsundungparameter,
Lipaz-Amelanz, Nieren-Funktionsparameter
anordnen.
Was erwarten Sie denn bei der Blutuntersuchung?
Ich erwarte in Labor
Lipaz-Erhörte.
Blutet.
Ja, nein.
Hemoglobin-Senkze.
Ja, so vermindert.
Das erwarten wir.
Schauen wir mal, ob das tatsächlich so ist.
Bei der endoskopischen Untersuchung,
wie heißt diese Untersuchung speziell?
Sie können die Abkürzung nehmen.
Ösafugao, Ösofago, Gastro,
Ösofago, Gastro, Deno-Scope.
Ö-Ged, das wurde so ein spielgeswort.
Ich muss da jedes Mal Buchstabieren.
Ja.
Für mich auch.
Was kann man bei den Ärzten,
die ich in der Zeit habe,
von wo zu stehen triggered,
die ich in der Zeit gebe,
die ich in der Zeit habe,
von wo zu stehen,
die ich auch in der Zeit habe,
das war ein bisschen durchfrischt?
Ja, diese Menschen,
die jetzt acht Jahre old- secondly
Genau. Und ja, möglicherweise, wenn man auch sieht, dass da was blutet, was könnte man dann auch noch machen?
Untersuchung oder...
Therapeutisch.
Wenn man sieht, dass da was blutet.
Therapeutisch, das ist ein Fehler.
Ich will die Situation aufnehmen.
Und ausreichende Flüssigkeit,
so kann ich das so legen.
Ja, also um zwei wenige Zugänge sicherlich, ja.
Und Flüssigkeitsgabe, ja. Also und was noch?
So demalde ich Schmerz adaptiertes Therapie und...
Lesen. Nein.
Ich kann das noch nicht erinnern.
Ja, also sie kriegt nichts zu essen, die wird intravenös ernährt, ne? Also Nahrungskarenz.
Nahrungskarenz?
Ja, macht sicherlich Sinn.
Und ja, unter Umständen kann man ja auch schon über die ÖGD, meine ich, auch schon, wenn da tatsächlich eine Blutung ist, die stillen mit einem, mit einem Clip oder mit einer Lasertherapie.
Oder...
Poterisation.
Ja.
Und gegebenenfalls Bluttransfusion?
Ja, genau. Dazu müssen wir vorher die Gruppe gut bestimmen, ne? Genau.
Und ja, wenn sich zeigt, dass Ursache ein Ulkos ist, was würde man da noch spezifisch untersuchen?
Helikobacter Piori.
Genau.
Helikobacter Piori ist häufig der Ursache, Ulkos von Trocchile. Ich würde 24 schütternden pH-Metrie...
Ja, pH-Metrie, ja.
...dorfführen.
Und...
Und wie genau ist das positiv ist?
Positiv ist Antioacida, Medikament verschreiben.
Ja, und Antibiose.
Ja, was für eine Antibiose?
Speziell.
Speziell bei HP.
Wie berühmt die Trippeltherapie?
Trippel, ja, echt.
Also zwei Antibiotika plus PPI.
Ja, das, ja.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr.
Ja.
Aber ich habe in diesem Fall grundliche Informationen.
Deshalb werde ich gastroenterologisch...
Logische?
Logische, Konzil.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja.
Das ist immer eine salomonische Lösung, nicht verfassend dazu.
Gut, okay.
Gut, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit der Patientin ist.
Und dann schauen wir die nachher an, wenn die in Ihrem Bett liegt.
Und gucken nochmal, wie es ihr geht und wie die Befunde alle zusammenpassen.
Ja.
Gut, ja, das war es für heute.
Sie haben gemerkt...
Ah, okay, das ist...
Eko.
Das ist die Trippeltherapie, ne?
Amoxicillin, Klaritromyzyn und PPI oder Metronidazone und Klaritromyzyn mit einem PPI.
Ich lese sofort.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das sind die beiden Trippelmuster.
Gut.
Ja, Sie haben gemerkt, die Anamnese ging eher glatt.
Und in dem Moment, als die Patientin nachgefragt hat, sind Sie ein bisschen ins Schwibben gekommen.
Denn Sie haben Schwierigkeiten, richtig zu formulieren, wenn Sie improvisieren müssen.
Wenn Sie auf eine Antwort geben müssen, ja.
Okay.
Wenn da etwas ist, was nicht so läuft wie erwartet.
In dem Augenblick wird es ein bisschen schwierig mit der Sprache.
Und jetzt muss ich gerade gucken, ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, nachher beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Unser erster Satz ist immer wieder ein Quelle, eine Fehlerquelle.
Ja.
Also, die Patientin stellt sich vor, wegen seit, was haben wir da, zwei Wochen aufgetretener,
zunehmender, dumpfer, epigaestrischer Schmerzen, irgendwie so etwas, ja.
Aber das Bestehen da, haben Sie nicht gesagt, ne?
Also, wegen, die Schmerzen bestehen ja immer noch, ja.
Das passt irgendwie in der Formulierung nicht.
Was soll ich reden, diese Tat?
Ja, also, man muss gucken, dass wirklich die Formulierungen drin sind, die entscheidend sind.
Dass man sagt, sie stellt sich wegen epigaestrischer Schmerzen vor.
Die bestehen schon länger, haben sich seit zwei Tagen verschlechtert.
Und sie bestehen aber jetzt im Augenblick immer noch und nehmen halt zu.
Und das muss halt irgendwie mit rein.
Ja.
Und dann haben sie schön gesagt, dass mit den begleitenden Nebel-Erscheinungen, also,
was weiß ich, dass sie, dass sie, dass sie, dass sie Himmels ist, hat,
dann, was mir aufgefallen ist, die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat dunklen Stuhl.
Daraus haben sie dunklen Urin gemacht.
Ah, ja?
Ich habe gehört, Urin, Wasser lassen, ich will nicht.
Nein, nein, also, ihr ist aufgefallen, dass, dass der Stuhlgang dunkle ist.
Ja, also, das spricht natürlich noch mehr für die Blutung als die, als der dunkle Urin.
Gut, dann haben sie gesagt, Fieber wurde verneint.
Aber die Patientin hat gesagt, sie fühlt sich fiebrig.
Ja, sie, aber sie hat nicht gemessen.
Ja.
Na, gut.
Dann haben wir diese Geschichte, was ich gleich gesagt habe.
Die vegetative Anamnese mit vier Punkten ist nicht mehr unauffällig,
sondern das ist eine auffällige Diagnose.
Wenn, ich denke immer, wenn ein Punkt ist, ja, was weiß ich, die vegetative Anamnese
ist bis auf Insum nie unauffällig.
Ja, okay, gut, das kann man vielleicht nur durchgehen lassen, ja.
Oder ja, je nachdem, was man sich bei einer Frau in den Wechseljahren könnte,
man vielleicht sagen, bis auf nächtliche Schweißausbrüche ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Ja, aber jemand, der also vier Sachen angibt, wie so es ihm schlecht geht,
das würde ich nicht mehr als unauffällig angeben, ja.
Gut, dann, das waren eigentlich auch von diese Dinge.
Sie haben dann gemerkt, ja, das ist mir aufgefallen,
wenn Sie doch schon über die Vorerkrankungen des Patienten oder der Patientin sprechen,
sagen Sie doch gleich dazu, welche Medikamente der dagegen nimmt, oder die, ja.
Dass man sagt, leidet, also, an Vorerkrankungen leidet sie seit zehn Jahren
an Atelingerle-Hypertonie und an Ormatoida arctritis.
Wegen der Hypertonie bekommt sie Kaptobril, wegen der Arctritis.
Ich muss Vorerkrankungen und Medikamente verbinden.
Ich würde das verbinden, weil es logisch ist, ja.
Und dann kann man sagen, im Jugendlichen Alter ist sie wegen eines Kreuzbandrisses operiert worden
und das sind ja keine Sachen, die da unmittelbar in dieses aktuelle Krankheitsgeschehen reinreichen.
Wenn es hier mal natürlich gerade vor acht Wochen eine Operation hatte,
dann müsste man vielleicht noch sagen, ja, was, was ich nach der Karzinomoperation
ist, die mit Chemotherapie behandelt, ja.
Das ist schon klar.
Aber so eine, ich denke mal, das ist schon logisch.
Bei den Vorerkrankungen, die Medikation gleich mit reinzuhängen.
Genau.
Dass es nicht so im leeren Raum steht.
Dann kam noch hier von Kollegen nach, die Magenschutz-Tabletten,
das fand ich einen guten Hinweis, dass sie tatsächlich gar nicht weiß,
was Magenschutz ist und sie nimmt halt auch nix.
Ja, aber wenn es dann tatsächlich losgeht, was zu machen ist,
sind sie ja immer auf der sicheren Seite.
Dann wissen sie immer ganz genau, was zu tun ist.
Und manchmal, wenn ich sie dann nachfrage, wissen sie nicht, was will sie jetzt,
aber sie labieren sich da ganz gut durch.
Und eigentlich meine ich, sind sie der Patientin ja ziemlich gut auf die
Spur gekommen, dass sie eine obere Blutung hat und dass sie wahrscheinlich
einen Ulgrus-Vertrick-Rekolli hat.
Das war es.
Ja, wie gesagt, die Formulierungen im freien Sprechen sind noch ein bisschen
wackelig.
Hören Sie viel rein, wenn andere sprechen, ja auch wenn Sie selber
gerade nicht an einem Nese machen, hören Sie mit zu und versuchen Sie,
vielleicht, wenn Sie ausgedruckte Anamnesen haben, es gibt ja viele
fertige Arztbriefe eigentlich, dass Sie die nochmal lesen und sich da
vielleicht noch die eine oder andere Formulierung ein bisschen
abgucken.
Das wäre vielleicht noch so eine Geschichte, damit Sie nicht jedes
Mal so überrascht sind, wie sage ich das jetzt, dass Sie auf
Formulierung zurückreichen, die sicher sind und wo Sie wissen,
ich bin vollständig in meinem Satz.
Ich muss lesen und lernen.
Ja, und immer wieder reden, das ist tatsächlich so. Man kann die
Sprache nur lernen, wenn man viel spricht.
Ja, genau.
Vielen Dank.